this is a mandatory process in china all
frozen seafood imports must be tested
for the coronavirus
after it was found on food packaging in
june last year
but the regulations are causing
congestion at ports and hundreds of
container ships are held up
in the north china i think somehow it's
more of a problem in north china
and less so in in shanghainengo and the
south
quite a lot of the cargos was diverted
to korean
ports some of the cargo's heading to the
north china
they have no choice then they directed
it to shanghai an outbreak in the
northeastern city of dalian last month
was linked to frozen food imports
dock workers who handled the goods
tested positive for covert 19
authorities blamed food packaging but
the world health organization
has questioned the link the reason that
some of those
food handlers
got infected is probably that they
did not practice any social distancing
measures the direct transmission of the
virus
from the contaminated food to human
beings that should be
very rare either way the restrictions
are causing long delays
and a shortage of imported food supplies
into china
the most immediate impact will be a
sudden imbalance of the flow
of the food supply you know into and
outside of china
china is still a country that is very
very very hungry for protein and china
despite
all the the natural resources is a huge
importer of great seafood from around
the world
the demand is quite high for the frozen
foods like
cherries from australia cherries from
chile
and also the frozen meat from brazil
here in hong kong the government has
followed china's lead and has now
extended testing to include frozen food
items
it's now testing a wider variety of food
items from around
30 countries the city's health chief
says the risk of infection from touching
the surface
of frozen packaging is minimal and so
far
no cases have been recorded the shortage
of port space
and risk of long delays has prompted
some companies
to cancel shipments to china but chinese
authorities
are showing no sign they'll ease up on
the regulations
sarah clark al jazeera hong kong